alors on a on avait le vine aussi kate
avec nous 18 ans il habite à gisors
élèves en bac pro transport toi alors
melvin temps grève de la faim je suis
j'ai commencé une grève de la faim
depuis ce matin juste pour l'instant t
c'était était bien non je me suis bien
on a commencé ce matin voilà j'ai mené
plusieurs grèves pourquoi tu mets une
grève de la faim
je mène une grève de la faim parce que
j'ai fait une première vidéo que j'ai
partagé sur les réseaux pour interpeller
à monsieur emmanuel macron ainsi que
monsieur jean michel blanquer
on n'a pas eu de réponse j'ai dit c'est
quoi votre vidéo elle déconseille tout
simplement les conditions dans laquelle
nous battre au on est par exemple dans
mon lycée le deux jours trois jours a
été mis en place donc deux jours en
présence et à 3 juin distant ciel les
les battrons pour la plupart ont pas le
droit c'est à dire on est à 100% de la
semaine en cours est à 100% on est tres
dans notre classe et ont des fois à une
trentaine pourtant on est mangée
transport ga nature et c2c des
conditions inadmissibles
ça me fait doucement rire quand monsieur
monsieur blanc caire parle de 2012 parce
que la demi-heure en pro pour l'instant
la connais pas du tout donc on est en
danger toute la semaine et les vidéos à
cette vidéo avait pour but de comme j'ai
dit dans la vidéo de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé tant connaître la situation et
donc j'ai fait une deuxième vidéo
alors vous allez dire tout ça à une
christine langue qui viennent avec nous
c'est là on dit que c'est la ministre
bis de l'éducation du mollet toutes les
questions il va pouvoir nous donner des
réponses et peut-être des solutions lui
dire tout ça qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous de ce qu'ils lisent déjà là
est ce que vous comprenez leur situation
jusqu'au bout dit non c'était un caprice
la situation allait profondément injuste
plein d'étudiants fossard qui a plein
d'étudiants qui réclament les examens en
contrôle continu
ils veulent pas faire les examens en
présentiel pourquoi parce qu'ils ont eu
des cours de manière très irrégulière
cette année et que les examens en
présentiel va pas se mentir ils ont de
fortes chances de louper dans examen
donc de redoubler
donc je pense ça va rajouter encore une
tannée alors année qui est déjà horrible
psychologiquement mais franchement si
l'état pouvait faire un effort et éviter
à ses étudiants de sombrer encore plus
dans la dépression en plus ça a coûté
énormément d'argent à tout le monde ses
redoublements donc qu'ils fassent un
état à un effort x files selon un
sondage à 91 % des lycéens qui
souhaitent passer le bac en contrôle
continu